foreign
hey everybody it's Tuesday time for
another movie review I'm gonna try to
get in the video yeah you're in the
neighbor's video yeah
that should happen I don't know you're
always going to the neighbors video I
don't know why you're doing that
invading their [__] they're like hey how
are you [__] yeah that's what
they're doing this is a good this was a
good movie I had forgotten because
here's the thing I probably saw this in
the late 80s because back then this came
out in 1982.
and it was like a big like cult classic
midnight movie type of thing like and I
always roll into like in high school I
was real into like all this golden Indie
movies and stuff like that so me and my
friends watched a bunch of these and I
remember really really liking it back in
the day but I hadn't seen it
since then I don't think I saw it since
I was in high school which was a long
time ago okay it was like the late 1980s
so I saw that it was on HBO Max and then
we were then I thought of it again
because we just did night of the Comet
not too long ago and that had Robert
Beltran and it also had Mary warrenov in
it and also had Paul Bartell in it uh
all three of whom are also in this movie
so I was like oh we should totally do
that movie so I put it in the poll I
think last week but it didn't win but
then I put it in again and it won this
time so I was like really and I and
watching it again last night I was like
oh my God I forgot how much I [__]
love this movie I love this movie this
movie is hilarious Jenny suggested it
because we did night of the Comet that
also had Robert Bell Transit yeah and um
he's he's the guy for who played chicote
from um Star Trek Voyager which that was
the only thing I knew him from I thought
he was great on Voyager even though I
don't really remember that program that
much but I don't remember all the
episodes I had to go back and watch it
but I remember liking it
and um when you saw him in his early
stuff what what impressed me about him
with night of the comet is that he he's
a good actor I mean he's got training I
checked his background he had a lot of
good theater training he was from
Bakerfield Bakersfield California
and uh parents of uh Mexican immigrants
so he's he's Chicago
um Bakersfield back in those days that I
don't know what it's like now but back
in those days that was upper middle
class so he he could he could have his
family got him some damn
acting training but he was good and um
in this one he knocks it out of the park
he does all kinds of funny [__] he's
he's he does a lot of good comedy in it
and he's got that dashing kind of
leading man look to him I don't know why
I guess he came out a little bit too
early to be in the rack pack because he
really should have been there with
Michael J fox and Tom Cruise and
everything he used to like at that level
um but he's good he's good actor and
[__] amusing
and uh I was just impressed with him
I can't believe that I only know him
from television I'm watching him I'm
going what does this dude remind me of
it reminded me of basically like uh
Chicano Don Johnson there's something
about the way he acts he's his facial
expressions or something just remind me
of Don Johnson
yeah I see what you're saying yeah is it
like that level you know he could have
played a really good cop role which you
know being a star Fleet officer you know
it's an official he was really good at
that as Chicago yeah so he could have
been her he could have been right on
Miami Vice been really good
I mean this in this movie it's like a
completely different uh role for him
yeah it's comedy he actually yeah I mean
he actually plays the titular Raul but
he's actually not like the star of the
movie he actually comes in like a little
bit later
but um he shines in it though yeah I
mean it's an impression the main three
actors in This are just like so so great
um mango said uh Bartel made some great
movies yeah Death Race 2000. yeah I
wanted to talk about that a little bit
because Paul Bartel uh who sadly passed
away back in 2000 uh but he's kind of
like I feel like he's sort of like an
unsung Indie movie hero you know what I
mean he made like so much good [__] he
worked with
um Roger Corman a lot back in the day
and he was actually paid I think five
thousand dollars like to direct Death
Race 2000 and which of course is a huge
cult classic but the thing about it was
that him and Roger Corman I feel like
they were always a little bit at odds
because Paul Bartel always wanted to go
like darker comedy and the way that
Death Race 2000 came out I mean that's
obviously like a very dark comedy as
well and I don't think that Roger Corman
was all that jazzed at how
it went in a more Darkly comedic route I
think he wanted it to be a little bit
more serious but you know I that can't
kind of came out later but the thing
about this movie was that Paul Bartel
was like you know I had worked for Roger
Corman and he was kind of like not super
happy with like the direction I was
taking things and then I had other
projects and you with Roger Corman and
they didn't get made so he's like I just
wanted to make the movie I wanted to
make because if you didn't know like
eating Raul he uh actually co-wrote and
directed this movie as well and this was
exactly what he wanted to do like with
no restrictions this was pretty much
like a completely independent
production like he borrowed 300 Grand
from his parents to make it pretty much
yeah um and one fact that I learned
about this which I think I guess is true
I've seen it in multiple times because
this has a Criterion Collection released
too and I think they mentioned it on
there but this movie was made entirely
from I think what they call short ends
like when you film a movie with like
with film stock it's like leftover film
stock that was unexposed that they
didn't use and they kind of keep it and
then later on they'll kind of like catch
it together like to use it you know to
to use it and this movie was made
entirely with that with short ends like
you know spliced together yeah so they
said that's why the um sometimes from
scene to scene like the uh the
appearance of it looks a little bit
different because they were all
different brands like some of it was
Kodak and so it was Fuji and so stuff
like that because they just to save
money I didn't either to be honest with
you to save money they just kind of like
use that because I guess that was just
it's like yeah we're not going to use
that here take these little scraps the
movie is about this couple they're kind
of square and yeah very Square yeah they
go to they go to LA
and they fall in into contact
with a bunch of pervy fetish people
and
um one thing leads to another they
figure out that they can
have in the newspaper kind of like a
fake dominatrix ad and get these uh
pervy people and get them come over and
kill them and Rob them yeah and make a
whole bunch of money I forgot what they
needed the money for they're uh a
restaurant restaurant that's right
that's their big dream was to open uh
Paul and Mary's Country Kitchen yeah no
they're now they hire a handyman to come
to set up the damn parlor he's supposed
to be a locksmith supposed to be a
locksmith but yeah he's just like a
contractor he kind of just does whatever
he has to at the time and um that's
where I will play well he's actually a
thief he's a thief actually the
locksmith is is covered that's his cover
like he comes in and he's like oh I'm
gonna install all locks and stuff on you
and then he makes keys of everything and
then he breaks in your [__] so he gets
involved and his handsome ass steals the
wife and tries to get the wife to kill
the ex the the husband and run off
together and it it's it and he wants you
know to live with them he wants to have
a nice house with [__] what do you
call it red velvet walls and it could
velvet wallpaper well and it's like I
laughed at that then I was kind of like
a real good Velvet paintings I I would
have red velvet wallpaper no I wouldn't
have black velvet well I don't know
maybe I would right but uh
a bunch of [__] happens during the movie
and what's funny is that it has the the
makings and the situations of something
like along the lines of a Rob Zombie
flick but the tone is totally different
I could see Rob's zombie taking this
idea and doing it his way and it ended
up being like something out of Devil's
Rejects because they're killing innocent
people you know mercilessly without any
[__] Mercy you know I love but
they're trying to make it look real
funny in this movie yeah
they kind of do that in in Rob Zombie
movies
The Killers think it's funny but you as
an observer don't think it's I don't
think it's funny that's the difference
where is that this one if you think it's
funny too it's yeah it's absolutely
hilarious which is kind of showing you
how degenerative you are you know
they're calling these victims degenerate
so let's kill them now you're degenerate
for doing this [__] no the whole I I
mean at least as I read it the whole
point of the movie is that they were
satirizing
um because Paul and Mary
Paul Bartel and Mary warrenov they use
their real names in this and that they
were actually like best friends uh they
worked together I think in 17 movies and
actually they played these same two
characters in shopping mall like they
made a cameo but they work together a
lot they were a lot of uh they were both
in the night of the Comet too like in
small yeah and I was just thinking
seeing this one wanted me to go back and
I wanted to go back and see night of the
Comet again yeah that was a good movie I
know I like it's a comfort food movie
yeah well it's still on shutter as far
as I know okay I think I wouldn't mind
owning that movie yeah yeah
this one was on I watched this on HBO
Max it might be on like other places too
but um the whole point of the movie was
that I mean this was the early 80s they
were um Paul and Mary were these real
uptight
kind of like 50s throwback sort of I
mean they they wore matching pajamas to
bed they slept in separate beds they
were almost like a 50s sitcom Yeah
couple is what they were trying to do
they even slept with like little
plushies which I thought was hilarious
like I can't remember what Mary's were
but Paul's was definitely like a wine
bottle because he was like a wine snob
which kind of like reminded me of like
sideways like Paul Giamatti and sideways
like later on but um but yeah so they so
they were kind of like they the two of
them weren't the heroes of the movie
they were kind of like making fun of the
fact that because the way that the movie
is the two of them are sort of like
these really really Square really
sexually repressed
people they don't even seem they're
married but they don't and they seem
like they're in love with each other but
they don't seem to have sex or anything
like that and they look down their noses
at this degeneracy that's Expo because
everybody else in LA in the real in the
um kind of context of this movie is like
a rapey yeah it's just it's just like a
total like sexual assault like a sexual
predator like every single person
right like and yeah like jumping on her
and like grabbing like the guy at the
bank that's like giving her a loan and
all this kind of stuff
to get the loan right so the thing about
it is that you're you're not seeing
things as they really are obviously
you're seeing things from their warped
perspective like they feel like oh where
are these pure 50s people but it's like
oh the 80s and it's just so degenerate
everyone's a degenerate I guess and so
they feel Superior to them but the funny
thing about it why this is a comedy is
that they feel justified in killing the
swingers because it's like who's gonna
miss a few perverts or something like
that but they're totally fine with
murder yeah
the funny thing about it too is that
they will absolutely do all the fetishy
stuff like fit like fake it
um to lure the people in to kill them
where you know if they were just like
more sex positive or something like that
they could just do that for real and
make money try to make more that's what
I'm saying but that's part of the joke
is that and they even go to the they
even go to the trouble of like dressing
up in costumes and like pretending that
they're doing that they're doing the
better stuff and then they come in and
like hit him with the with the cast iron
skillet and like kill them but it's like
you know if they really wanted to kill
them why didn't they just kill them when
they walk in the door you know what I
mean there's an element of Truth in this
because we've covered certain serial
killer cases in the show where they were
like this lately like the uh the dudes
down here in Florida with the fitness
guy who abducted the other dude yeah
they could have made just money in the
damn Fitness industry instead of
dressing up like ninjas and trying to
hold dudes hostages and [__] they
they didn't make any money doing that
[__]
thinking their criminal masterminds you
know what I'm talking about yeah from uh
painting Aid yeah yeah so there are dumb
ass Crooks
yeah that that that's what they're doing
but right but I'm just saying that the
whole point of them being like that in
the movie was it was like making fun of
them it's like you know if you guys
weren't so sexually repressed and if you
don't didn't feel Superior to these
perverts then you could just make money
doing that like they do like the
dominatrix character yeah we did but
it's like instead you're killing people
and they're fine with it they're very
like matter of fact about killing these
people because they see them as trash so
they're kind of like making fun of the
they were doing the Finish thing pretty
much anyway that's that's what I'm
saying yeah they could have just so they
were so the movie was important for
nothing right well and the movie is kind
of like making fun of their hypocrisy
like in that way just because it's like
oh you'll do it like to be fake they
even had to kill the dog I guess they
did Kill the dog yeah they didn't share
that but they I mean they talked about
it yeah but yeah but so I don't know if
you guys haven't showed up with a big
old Great Dane and when uh and she he
wanted to see her have sex with great
day I mean that was the implications to
say that but but I'm pretty sure when he
shows up he's a little person with this
great day yeah and uh he's going oh he
likes you already that's the last time
you see him but she was saying I guess
we had to kill the dog too you know he's
like yeah they killed Doug yeah but yes
like a lot of it was implication too
like but yeah I'm pretty sure that they
implied that they wanted her to have sex
with the dog she didn't like actually
have sex with the dog because they were
killing the people they're calling you
um but yeah so that's the thing and I
like I said I kind of feel like that was
the funniest thing about it to me was
that because I think you missed the very
beginning yeah but there was kind of
like a um
like a little bit of a it almost seemed
like one of those uh kind of VoiceOver
like shorts where they're kind of like
you know LA and it's so degenerate and
like every you know everybody is a
pervert and like they showed people
getting like snatched off the street and
like raped in cars and all this other
kind of stuff so they're kind of setting
up this
unrealistic framework that's kind of
like obviously outlandish and obviously
ridiculous but it's kind of like what
some people were maybe thinking La was
really like like everything was just
this Cesspool of perversion and
everything like that so they took that
like to its logical extreme and like
made a joke about it but they weren't
like real
over the top the movies ridiculous and
it's outlandish and stuff like that but
I think it works because the two
characters at the center of it are
almost kind of like sympathetic like you
kind of feel sorry for them but they're
just so like I said they're just so
matter of fact about everything like
they don't get super upset because how
they get into the whole murder thing
they don't do it on purpose at least
initially what ends up happening is that
they live in this apartment building and
um apparently like all the all the other
apartments being taken over by all these
perverts that are moving in like that
have all these big orgies and swingers
parties and stuff and they're very
scandalized by all of this because like
I said they're very proper like kind of
50s people
so even they they even have like a lot
of kind of 50s sort of stuff like in
their apartment you know what I mean
like not real obviously but a little bit
so what ends up happening is that they
their big dream is to open a restaurant
like a Country Restaurant their last
name is Bland by the way so that should
tell you something
um Mary and Paul Bland that's what their
names are
so they want to open this country
restaurant I kind of felt like it was
maybe something like Cracker Barrel I I
kind of thought I don't know if they had
Cracker Barrel back then but that was
kind of the vibe that I got
so uh so they want to do that
now uh Mary is a nurse and she's just
being constantly like sexually harassed
by her patients uh you know so again
again because everybody in La is
apparently like a huge pervert and and
uh the other guy and Paul like works at
a liquor store but he's again like a
wine snob so he's like um ordering these
really really expensive bottles of wine
and like the owner is like dude like we
don't have the clientele like to buy
these what are you doing
um so he gets fired so now they're kind
of like worried about they're behind on
their bills and it's like we're never
going to open our restaurant now and
then it so happens that one of the
swingers next door comes over to their
apartment and essentially just like
walks in and tries to like rape her
because like I said everyone is just
like a caricature
and um so in self-defense kind of like
Paul just like whacks him over the head
with a frying pan and kills him and then
they're just like and I love his
reaction to it too he's like he just
keeps hitting the guy in the head with
the pan and she's like stop he's dead
it's like I'm pretty sure he's dead and
the guy's just like oh [__] that's all I
need and then they just stuff him in a
bag and like just throw him down the
garbage Chute or whatever into the
incinerator
and so after that like they take all the
money out of his wallet because he had
like 600 bucks and then they're like
yeah these perverts they always have all
this money and after
um Barry gets turned down for a bank
loan uh and the bank the bank loan
officer's name is Mr leech which again
very obvious
um he was played by Buck Henry who was
actually the he wrote the screenplay for
uh The Graduate actually
so he's won a couple Oscars and stuff
like that for his screenplays but yeah
so he was in it so he straight up tries
to rape her and so she doesn't get the
loan obviously because she's very prim
and proper but after that they're just
like well why don't we just
um you know kill these people because
they have money and it's like they're
just trash and they're just perverts and
nobody cares so that's what they do so
they go and like talk to this dominatrix
that was at this party that they went to
and she tells them she's like yeah why
don't you just run an ad and I think
that it was called like the Hollywood
press or something like that and have
like all these people come over so then
like the middle whole middle part of the
movie is them doing like all these
ridiculous like fetish scenarios like
there's this one guy that comes over
that wants to dress up like a Nazi and
like and like whip her and like try to
get her to give them information and
then Ed Begley Jr is in here like he
wants her to dress up like a hippie so
he can come there and like um castigate
her for protesting the Vietnam War and
like beat the [__] and he like tries to
rape her as well and so because like I
said it's just kind of like so
um at some point like Raul
who is uh Robert beltran's character
like I said he starts out as like a
locksmith and he comes over to put new
locks on their apartment because it's
like well you know all these swingers
keep like wandering into her apartment
and we have all these expensive wine
bottles and [__] like that
so he comes over to put new locks in but
it turns out that he's a crook and his
whole locksmith thing is just a cover so
he can make keys for people's locks and
like break into their [__] so he breaks
into their house and sees the body at
which point they have to like make a
deal with him and he's like hey I know a
guy that can get rid of these bodies for
you if you split the money with me and
what they're ended up doing with the
bodies is they're taking him to a dog
food plant and grinding them up into dog
food so as I said it almost sounds like
and I was reading like Roger Ebert uh
reviewed this movie like went back when
it came out in 1982 and he said it's
almost like motel hell I guess this he
likes Motel Hell better I like I like
this one but I like motels I like them
both I like them both but I think I like
this one better there's just something
about this one it's obviously very low
budget I think it only costs 350 000 to
make
um you know and it kind of shows like
it's you know it's obviously an
independent movie but there's something
about the tone of this like just I mean
it is just laugh out loud funny and
maybe that's just my sense of humor I
guess but I don't know I had forgotten
how [__] hilarious this movie was I
was just like watching because like I
said I haven't seen it for probably like
30 years at least and we were like
watching it last night and I was just
busting out laughing like a bunch of
times it's just so so funny and
I don't know like I was watching another
review of it and he said well if you
changed a few things around this could
absolutely be a horror movie because of
the subject matter yeah it is very dark
subject it's not bloody or anything like
that like they don't show anybody
getting it's not graphics not even
violent no it's not like I said that you
know yeah he kills people with the I
like how he kills people with the
skillet like every time yeah and like
the funny thing too is like he goes out
to like the grocery store or something
and she's just like very casually it's
like can you get us another Skillet I'm
just like I'm kind of squeamish about
cooking food and like the thing that we
used to kill all these people like just
very very matter of fact it's just like
they're they're absolutely like not even
worried that they're like murdering
people and like just sending to me like
ground up in a dog food and just like I
think their their lack of emotion about
it and just their matter the whole
matter of fact like deadpan kind of
thing about it is the funniest thing
about it to me
for some reason I just I just find that
very very funny
mango says Buck Henry was in the man who
fell the Earth also that's right he was
wow it's been a while
since we reviewed that but yeah
um Camp guy says a Great Dane is one of
the best jump scare dogs if you go over
someone's house and one jumps out around
a quarter yeah they're huge
um where my mom used to live they had a
great dane and it was as big as me like
when it stood up like it put my pop its
paws on my shoulders and it was taller
than I was and they tend to be chilled
out dogs though I would hope so yeah
because man that's [__] everyone I've
ever seen was just keeps cool yeah
uh cam guy said Buck Henry reminds me of
Henry Gibson yeah they do kind of look
alike
uh both from the same era yeah Gibson
was great in Nashville and Magnolia yeah
he was in The Burbs also we were talking
to we're just talking about The Burbs
the other day because
um the guy that voiced Gollum was also
in The Burbs
but yeah so I mean if you like black
comedies from the 1980s uh this is a
really really good one and I kind of
feel like
I kind of feel like a lot of people
don't really talk about it anymore and
that's kind of like a shame because this
movie is so [__] funny I mean I find
it funny I don't know if everybody else
would but
I don't know like I've seen a lot of
other reviews of it and a lot of other
people like seem to think it's like
really really it's a decent movie
especially for a um an independent film
it doesn't
it doesn't really feel like an
independent film it just feels like a
like a like a low budget well
I guess a lot of the low budget movies
we've watched were kind of independent
so maybe maybe it does yeah and like I
said this is exotic or you know just
yeah this is exactly what Paul Bartel
wanted to make because I mean this was
completely independently financed and
it's decent I I'm gonna give it to
[__] night of the Comet though uh in
terms of a belltran flick I liked him
better than that one I think that's
actually a better movie
um or at least now I want to say that
it's more of my tastes right something
like that whereas I feel like I like
this one more I like both of them but
this one's more because I really really
like black comedies and I know that
they're I think they're a more divisive
genre all together maybe
kind of like Death Becomes Her and
[__] Little Shop of Horrors it's it's
that type of movie it's just not quite
the same budget yeah this one gives me a
little bit of a job it's it's gives me a
little bit of a John Waters Vibe as well
yeah
um well you know I don't know that I
don't think I've ever seen a John Waters
yeah we discussed that before okay I
still can't believe that you've never
seen it down I have to show you one at
some point
you probably you'd probably like um I
imagine you'd probably like cry baby
okay
yeah that's that's a good one Tracy
Lords and and
um
yeah I remember when that came out I
thought you had seen hairspray I mean I
know we watched the remake of hairspray
that had John Travolta in it in the
Divine role but the original one's a lot
better you never saw hairspray with
Ricky Lake I don't think I know I don't
think I ever saw hairspray with John
Travolta in it but no we did because we
watched it together I didn't I didn't I
don't remember it I mean the original is
a lot better the Remake was all right
too but I liked the original a lot
better but yeah so I mean this movie
like I said Paul Bartel wrote it he also
co-wrote it with um Richard Blackburn
who is also in this movie he actually
played James uh the the real estate
agent that's like trying to get them the
building that they want for the
restaurant and they said again to save
money not only did they use all the film
short ends and everything but pretty
much everybody other than the principal
characters in this is like members of
the crew also because they were just
kind of like oh and the guy that plays
there's a great scene where uh where
Paul goes to a sex shop like to buy some
stuff and the guy behind the counter
it's just like this really hilarious you
have to see it it's like this really
hilarious scene where the guy's like
trying to sell him all this stuff and
that guy like behind the counter they
wanted
um Paul ribbons for that you know PeeWee
Herman yeah um and he either didn't want
to do it or couldn't do it or something
like that but he's like oh um you know
use this other guy and that guy would go
on to be I can't remember what his name
is he had like a [__] what was his
name Paragon I think I feel like his
last name was Paragon or something like
that it was a word and uh he ended up
being on peewee's Playhouse like later
on but that guy is [__] great like
the way he's just like trying to sell
him like all this [__] sex toys and
stuff because like I said the funniest
thing about this movie to me
is that one these two are just totally
fine with murder they just they kill a
guy and they're just like oh [__] well
whatever and then they're like oh maybe
we should do that again because we made
a lot of money and they're just like
totally they're not conflicted about it
they don't give a [__] about it or
anything like that it's not a lot of
Mines couple like a couple hundred bucks
right well and that's the thing like
when Raul comes into the picture which
is kind of like you know they kind of
have to bring him in because he's like
well I could go to the cops well they're
like well you can't go to the cops
because you broke into our house so
they're like okay we're kind of at an
impasse so like we should work together
and he knew a way to get rid of the
bodies like I said because he knew a guy
that had that could grind them up for
dog food and so they had to kind of like
do this thing but he was saying it's
like yeah you're doing all this work and
you're just only making a few hundred
dollars per person because they were
just taking whatever money they had out
of the thing but the thing they found
out later was that Raul was also taking
uh the people's clothes and their cars
and selling those and not telling Paul
and Mary about it so he was even getting
more money on the side so when they
found out about that then Paul Bartel
tried to hire the dominatrix to do role
play and like try to get rid of him
because he started had started like
[__] the wife you know what I mean
because the the wife and them started
having an affair how's she gonna resist
look at the difference between Beltran
and beltran's middle name his last name
is Perez but look at look at the
difference between Fayette is in her and
her supposed husband all right
even though that woman if you ask me man
she was probably what six foot one she
was tall
she started out in uh Andy warhol's
stuff yeah very well known and I think
she was in Chelsea girls and she was in
like a lot of his early films did some
stuff with the Velvet Underground all
that kind of stuff yeah and she's been
in a [__] ton of movies man yeah [__]
on
she's kind of cool there's something
yeah there's something about her I mean
uh she kind of gave me gave me that late
70s early 80s porn star Vibe actually
that's not what she is but in this movie
she gives off that Vibe which is funny
because they're supposed to be they're
supposed to be up tight but she kind of
wears some [__] scandalous [__] well
that's like I said that's kind of part
of the humor yeah is that she's supposed
to be there straight away [__] yeah yeah
she's supposed to see this real straight
lace but it's like then they're like oh
well we'll do all this like fetishy [__]
like she wears a Minnie Mouse costume at
one point like some kind of s m stuff
and when she goes to get their loan you
she's wearing a dress you can see right
through you can see her underwear
through it yeah that's well like I said
that's why part of the joke that they
don't it's it's not like super obvious I
guess but it's like they they're kind of
pointing out the hypocrisy that it's
like you know they're talking about how
Superior they are and how straight laced
they are and it's like oh everyone else
is filthy degenerates but then they do
the same kind of [__] but like it's okay
when they do it cheating on her husband
well that ended up too you know and I
think you missed too like that I think
there was a scene like toward the
beginning that you missed with uh one of
the patients because she was a nurse
like I said
um that was like really like sexually
harassing her like big time and she like
ended up she was gonna give him an enema
but then like she did this whole
Switcheroo where she made like this old
grizzled old dude like dude
so that was a great scene too but like
this whole movie is just like full of
great scenes I don't know what it is
it's like there's just something about
these kind of like early 80s Indie
flicks and especially like dark comedies
I especially really like dark comedies
um and this one man like I said I hadn't
seen it for so long and watching it last
night I just forgot how [__] funny
this was I was just dying it's [__]
hilarious it's punching above its weight
if you look at the budget yeah yeah I
mean it's hilarious yeah it's it's a
good flick and the fact that they made
it for that little amount of money and
it made like okay money like it made
over a million dollars it was good
writing good acting the edit is pretty
good
um score was good I mean I mean it was
it's a well-crafted little movie yeah
and uh everybody in it is having a good
time at the hot tub party where they
electrocute everybody they're getting
naked and [__] I think I I think I saw a
porn star in there from the 80s what'd
he say swing on this [__] and he
throws like the space shooter in the hot
tub with all the swingers yeah they're
jumping it so there's that electric heat
though they're a bunch of [__] film
people having fun making this yeah it
was Paul Bartel and all his friends yeah
and I think that was so this was like
exactly the movie that he wanted to make
it was a very much a scene movie it was
like all his buddies so it kind of It
kind of uh it it it kind of exudes kind
of a weird positivity to it that they're
they're [__] with you they're having
fun yeah it's a dark subject you know
but it's still scary and it's no it's
it's not scary it's not graphic or
anything like that like it goes to some
Dark Places yeah there's cannibalism in
it yeah uh you know there's people
murder murder people being ground up in
a dog yeah these two are like
essentially serial killers they're
serial killers yeah they would have been
considered cereal oh [__] yeah yeah
they had dudes that were doing this kind
of [__] remember the old [__] dude
who worked at the damn Pig
slaughterhouse the pig farm yeah Willy
picked and yeah and killing all the
hookers and there were women that knew
that he was doing that that was some
weird [__] man
yeah feed them to the pigs
yeah this kind of like so it it's very
very dark subject matter but it's
treated very deftly yeah and it's kind
of like
it's weird I always it almost has like a
little bit I don't know I don't almost
like a little bit of a punk rock like
kind of sensibility to it you know what
I mean I don't know yeah that kind of
thing seamsters and stuff yeah yeah
because like I said everybody it's just
hilarious they were hanging out the club
right and it's and it's hilarious to me
too House Parties the way they make the
way they portray La in this movie
because it's like they're it's like
they're portraying it subjectively like
Through The Eyes of the main characters
who are like super uptight yeah and
they're talking about the fetish The
Fetish scene right and the way it's
handled they know about the fetish seat
yeah so they got friends in it you know
or they're in it you know just so I love
that the zombie movie I love that the
dominatrix character like when they go
to her house like to ask her for advice
like how do we you know they didn't say
like how do we lure people there to
murder them but she's like you know we
want to get into this like how do we do
it and so they go to her house and she's
just like even though she's like this
big Dominatrix and she's always always
like you know whipping people and [__]
like that but they just show her as like
a completely normal like Suburban mom
she's got like her little kid in the
high chair and she's cutting up some
food for her she's been a listener it's
like so so funny if you've been a
listener for a long time me and Jenny's
got all kinds of friends from my
ex-girlfriend and [__] they're all into
that [__] they're always inviting us
lately they've been inviting us to go to
damn secrets
and uh
but um and then like having parties at
Brian and Becky's house and
they're big into that fetish scene and
[__] and having girlfriends living with
them and everything and then they had
teenage teenage daughter who's just
looking at them like you guys are [__]
up
well yeah but it's kind of like from
absolutely fabulous you know I mean
where they're the the
daughter remember the daughter yes our
friend yeah yeah it's [__] funny I
love that [__] [__] yeah
she was just like horrified that her
that her mom and her mom's best friend
are just like complete degenerators yeah
you're right yeah
she wasn't a little kid she was 18. yeah
she was a kid she was yeah she was like
a she's just a young adult she's just
embarrassed by her parents but everybody
is that's the thing and that's what I
think that's what's kind of so funny to
me is that because we know a lot of
people that are into this kind of stuff
and it's like they have grown kids and
it's always funny to me like how the
kids are just like oh gross it's great
it's always gross when it's your parents
dude you know what I mean even if I was
into like some particular [__] and like
my parents were doing it you'd be like
yeah you know what I mean because that's
just kind of how stuff works I guess but
uh but yeah so this movie
like I said it did make um pretty decent
money got pretty decent uh critical
thing it was it was kind of like a big
midnight movie like I said I remember
like in the 80s like they'd always do
like little showings of it and stuff
they did actually do a stage musical
adaptation of it in the 19 in the early
1990s
um and they were going to do Paul Bartel
like I said he passed away but they were
actually going to do a sequel yeah uh in
which somebody found out about what they
were doing because spoiler alert they
get away with it there's no consequences
they get they don't get caught I thought
that was kind of unique I know I was
just like they'd show them at the end
going like hey we got our restaurant
they got the 25 000 or whatever it was
they needed to buy it
and it was just like I thought that was
like really funny it's funny that you
said they made a show about it because I
was thinking at the time I was watching
it it would have been pretty good to see
that with Rocky Horror Picture Show and
something like uh Sweeney Todd is is in
that
how fun would that have been you could
do kind of like a cannibalism yeah I
mean I kind of feel like it oh this
would be so cool like if there's like
some indie theater out there like around
here that wants to do that you could do
like a whole we'll do Native cannibalism
and you can have this movie you can have
this only has a little bit of
cannibalism it's most I was like they
just referred to it yeah they just they
don't show it or anything now Rocky
Horror does have some cannibalism in it
too because they eat Eddie um you know
the meatloaf character yeah so um then
you could do like motel hell you could
do like so all the like fun cannibalism
movies you know what I mean like the
dark comedies about cannibalism oh you
could even show parents from 1989 that
would be another good one so you could
do it uh which I reviewed I don't think
you've seen it though
but uh but yeah that would be another
good because that's another black comedy
like about cannibalism but they were
gonna do a sequel to this movie and it
was gonna be called Bland ambition
because because that was their last name
oh yeah Paul and Mary Bland so it was
going to be called Bland ambition
and it's like well one of the funny
things so their last name is Bland and
I'm pretty sure that at one point
because they were gonna open this
restaurant at one point he said to her
like they were gonna call it what oh man
what enchiladas Bland enchiladas that's
what they were they were gonna call him
she's like that's my specialty so they
were gonna put that on the menu the
Bland enchiladas and I can't remember
what else because they were coming up
with some um
uh I can't remember what the first name
for the restaurant they had was because
after that they kind of referred to as
like oh it'll just be Paul and Mary's
Country Kitchen or something like that
but they had another name before that
but it was something else with Bland in
it which I thought was like really funny
and they were just like and they talked
about it like it was normal like people
would be like well maybe we shouldn't
name the restaurant like something with
Bland in it because that was their last
name but it's like I thought that was
funny that they didn't comment on it but
as like everything about this movie is
like hilarious like I don't I don't know
why this movie's so funny to me but
everything about it is funny to me and I
had forgotten how [__] funny it was
but I was just like laughing through the
whole [__] thing you know what I mean
yeah Tammy says uh absolutely fabulous
is one of my all-time favorite shows
yeah mine too mine too honestly I like a
lot of
I don't like a lot of Comedy but when I
like comedy it tends to be black comedy
or it tends to be like British comedy
which some I don't know something about
that is like much funnier to me than
like American Comedy so yeah like
absolutely fabulous I love like a lot of
old British comedies like the young ones
and the comic strip which was more like
surreal uh you know I love like Eddie
Izar and I love like all that kind of
stuff I also liked Little Britain
although I only saw I don't know how
many seasons I know they call it series
over there but um I don't know how many
seasons of that there was but I did see
like the first couple seasons and I
thought those were like super funny
because that seemed like it had like a
young one's kind of vibe too because it
was just like
grow it was kind of like the greasy
Strangler a little bit in a little way
where it was just kind of like making
fun of like these gross ass people you
know what I mean but uh yeah I liked
that as well but I haven't seen a lot of
we have britbox
and I always kind of feel like oh I
should go in there and like check out
some new stuff because I've heard
there's some new things that are good
but and everybody keeps recommending
peaky blinders also
and maybe we should get around to
watching that one of these days but I've
had a lot of people recommend that
but yeah so
um
if you have HBO Max
and you like 80s movies and you like
dark comedies
then you should totally watch this
because this is a great movie and I feel
like a lot of people don't
don't talk about it it's short it's only
like 83 minutes
um and
I don't know I just laughed the whole
[__] way through it everything about
this movie is [__] funny to me and I
don't know what else to tell you you
know yeah
um but yeah so you have anything else
you would like to add no I think we've
covered it at least twice
all right [__] it's [__] in circles
okay well we're not well just because
you're just sitting there not saying
anything so I'm just saying everything I
can say about it I said everything I
could say about it it's decent movie
it's good Richard Brown said have you
seen blood sucking freaks I have but it
was a a while ago I don't think we ever
reviewed it though did we hmm never
heard of it
I don't remember if we reviewed it but I
have seen it like a few years ago
um let me see uh mango said parents with
Randy Quaid is very good yeah I I
reviewed parents probably
a year or ago maybe not even that long
ago like look at if it's on my flickers
of fear series I did that because that's
another movie that I feel like um a lot
of people don't talk about anymore even
though it's like really really funny
it's not
it's slightly different than it's kind
of like a similar vibe to this one I
guess like I think eating Raul is more
like overtly funny whereas parents is
more
Sinister and the humor isn't quite as
overt but it's kind of in the same
ballpark I feel like maybe you know what
I mean I've never seen it Camp guy said
is this the one with the scene at the
hot tub yeah yeah where he throws the
thing in parents is actually set in like
an idealized 1950s and it's kind of like
Leave it to Beaver If the parents were
cannibals and like it's from their kids
point of view and he's like oh my God my
parents are cannibals you know what I
mean but it's it's almost like a horror
movie like it's kind of creepy this
one's not creepy this one's just pretty
overtly a comedy even though like the
you know the subject matter is dark that
one is kind of more
in a gray area you know what I mean
because it's not as overtly funny and it
also has like creepy [__] in it too
yeah they throw a space heater into the
hot tub and it kills all because uh
because at this swingers party you know
ever all the naked people is like
everybody has to get into the hot tub so
they all get into the hot tub and like
he's like and he prefers the heater and
there electrocutes everybody
but uh but yeah all right so we are
gonna wrap it up now tomorrow night is
our main show and Paul and I've said
Paul because I was looking at the
looking at the notes because of Paul
Bartel
um but Tom will be very excited to know
we're doing another UFO show no we're
doing the Belgian wave oh yeah yeah okay
okay
so I'm I'm well versed in it so what we
might do this evening is because
Unsolved Mysteries did a show Belgium
featuring that you want to see it again
and we can watch it it's on two because
I already looked it's season season four
episode yeah I've seen it many times I
love it I've seen it too I love that one
but yeah that'd be a good refresher
course yeah yeah there's a lot of good
[__] in that so that should be a fun
show yeah that happened
I know the Belgian wave happened you
just well we'll see yeah I believe they
did well [__] man the Air Force [__]
well the Air Force did fly up we're
going to talk about the other day
there's a possibility it could have been
some radar false radar returns but yeah
because uh they were using a radar
sometimes malfunctioned but nah the cops
the Shonda Maurice all kinds of weird
[__]
I believe they saw it
Trey just got here and said [__] I'm
late it's all right you missed it yeah
well I mean at least you can go back and
watch it yeah but yeah this is a great
[__] movie go watch it like I said
it's on HBO Max and tomorrow night we're
doing a show about Belgian UFO wave yeah
so everybody will be excited about that
yeah Jeff here I said wow Belgian wave
and Tom Park's right up yeah yeah
yeah all right so we will see you guys
again uh tomorrow night thanks very much
for dropping by for the discussion good
night